yeah so Thank You Jared and thanks
everyone for being here and on this
sweaty July day am I on
Brittany pack
yeah okay I'm just gonna put that there
all right all right
so lighter scale they wouldn't trust us
most designers but the REIT that that
makes things different machine the
virtual machine has its own operating
system don't file systems its own
collections of life binary program data
with it and then the apps that are
running in that virtual machine as well
and you on the same physical
infrastructure each of which will have
operating system and their own file
system and all of these things together
and that lets them operate as isolated
environments however it's really
resource intensive because each of them
needs to host machines and all of that
that CPU thing through a much lighter
weight infrastructure so first of all
docker in dr. all your virtual machines
share the same operating system and
they're sort of an agreement from the
start all docker is all docker isolate
environments our Linux environment so
that sounds like a decision made from
the start everything you don't have to
hook multiple types of operating systems
but actually they're all simultaneously
operating same and running the operating
system or kernel at the same time so
your machines can share that they can
also share components of their file
systems or their software libraries or
component to the software that's
installed even though they're isolated
or running environments with the own
memory on their own ass and for that
reason you can run a lot of docker
containers on a lot less infrastructure
and they're able to start up and down
faster and be orchestrating as a group
much faster now this in the bit self
doesn't make it you person whose job is
primarily to analyze the data
their own environment you're not
necessary building things the map across
the world but the fact this becomes
popular amongst all those people has
made doc her kind of ubiquitous so
docker can scale it's used by so many
organizations at this point it can be a
standard for isolating environments that
lot knowledge is huge and that means
that you get weird images like this
which is from Amazon Web Services doctor
orchestration hub in which you get to be
the space 9 moving around a lot of ships
containers and those containers are all
on one hand isolating environments but
the other reason that sort of container
metaphor works is they're all the things
that can be moved around and lots of
people can use in lots of different
places the ubiquity of the doctor
container as a standard means that an
isolating environment that you create is
an isolated environment on somebody
else's computer or lots of times
thousands and thousands of computers in
a bigger so I want to jump right in it's
actually running some things and showing
some examples but first what I want to
do is make sure we all sort of a bare
minimum of understanding of vocabulary
and actions and commands so in docker
this is thing called an image an image
is the wrapped up package everything in
a doctor environment did have the files
of the operating system descriptions of
environment variables and other things
that might affect affect your work
that's the package and the package that
can move around when you take that
package in a run it and create the
machine that's running in a nice lid
environment that's called a container so
you have an image that's static and a
container that there's also something
called a docker file the docker file is
merely a script that runs a series of
commands that creates an image so an
image can be a big thing it's megabytes
and gigabytes of information because it
has all the file systems all
installs the script is just what that
you can be just a short series of
commands that define these dependencies
inside it and then there's something
called docker hub docker hub is a
service online where people can share
docker images and one of the things
about within it docker hub is not the
only place you can do this much like the
pub and get lab and you can have private
instances and do it on your own services
but doctor hub is by far as the most
ubiquitous and widely used and sort of
the default of most people go to when
they're sharing things at least four
images so this is object we think of
then there's the actions so you give a
bare minimum of commands docker is a lot
like git it's a program that you're
running on your computer
everything you do starts with the word
doctor then there's and then a million
that can be funny but ultimately you're
really only doing this and that was just
a short number of them by the way all
this life yup in addition to my talk and
I'm also gonna have a bunch of code up
there for you to see as well so you
don't have to worry about examples - so
does dr. pol which means you're gonna
get an image from another repository
from maybe your organization's croc
there's dr. bill which is take a nap dr.
image to give it a name so that you can
use it again
when you have it you can if you put say
doc give an image name
it'll container and container is an
isolated environment you usually have to
specify how you want to get data in and
out I communicate with it and for that
there's usually specified you got to
communicate with the machine wit which
is sort of how you communicate via no
poison Sheridan the isolating computer
running inside it you might specify some
other commands about what you want to
him in portal a default one and you may
or may not say detach another painter in
the background or front of you as it's
going and that container doesn't there's
doctors there are a thousand other
doctors commands but this is probably
most of what you're gonna use and you're
probably gonna use a subset of these
because one of the nice things about
docker or wrong is it it'll or
automatically built it hasn't been built
already through depth very these
commands are generally run you can a
terminal with are and all of these
things can be done in R as well are
being are there are at least three
packages for running docker suprise
surprisingly I mean they're actually all
they're all pretty good and they all
pretty much do the same thing and the
API for them is not that different so I
don't have a written recommendation as
to which one you use I like this one
called stevedore it's partially because
of my friend rich bich John has written
it partially cuz it has some particular
small advantages that I like but it's
not super important most of these things
work the same so to do all the things
that I just described that you would do
in the terminal you
do it in our by loading the stevedore
library you start what's called the
docker client just so it's communicating
with the docker software and then just
like in the shell you can pull an image
with an hour vision you can build an
image with an hour function you can take
an image and start a container with it
specifying your ball their command and
you can stop that container and you can
do that all in your art console your
scripts as well
so why would you actually use this this
is actually the part that I think like
most introductions to the docker kind of
skip over because they assume you know
why you're using it and or they like
assume a particular reason for using it
and that can vary a great deal whether
you're a person who's using it to build
a web service or trying to pack it to
scientific analysis all of which you
might be using is not I sort of break
these up into four major categories of
how you might be using docker one is
largely about reproducibility to like
build a working environment that you can
be sure that things will run the same
way and from place to place that's one
of those sort of sort of core are our
reasons a reproducibility but you also
might be using docker to run a different
program for our to access to call you
might be using docker to run and our
thing that you want a different program
of service to call or you might be using
docker as a way to ship around your sort
of intensive compute jobs so they can be
run on different infrastructure all
those things share some components but
there are different sort of patterns of
working if you're working in a fixed
environment what really matters is
what's inside the container on top of
the whale so what you want when you are
working on a primary our analysis within
a dr. container is to have all of the
tools that you want to do your data
science process your analysis within
that be it our our studio the data the
extra libraries you might be using and
you want all those all packaged inside
in
way that they're like locked and they're
a time capsule and your colleague or
yourself six months from now after
you've upgraded your operating system
can I run those things so it's really
just you know it's the lock box in this
case when you're doing something like
this you have let me skip this is an
example of why you might want to use do
anything like this so this is a
screenshot of the Tauri of mine
associated with a bunch of work we did
and eco health alliance and published a
paper associating with it and we tried
to do a really good job of making it
possible for other people to also run
this okay so we made a make file so we
could you know run one command to do all
the different components of it we use
pak-rat
to save our packages you know we have
extensive documentation you see the
bottom of the description of the file
tree of what all the files are and as I
was writing it up I said okay well you
need all these packages we have packraft
and we have the make file and we have
this description and also you need cairo
and geology Osen magic and java and curl
and PNG and all of these things and you
note at the time I did not think to put
the verse off you know and you know we
did manage to run it on two different
computers so it did actually happen at a
certain point kale is in the back
smiling there cuz his laptop was the one
that took a couple of days for it to
happen on but you know like you sort of
had this shift around the pieces and I
don't know if we wrote down everything
the one needs to do for this and then
you end up with this problem which was
really well outlined by this paper last
year in Nature Biotechnology where even
if you get the thing to run people have
slightly different versions of the
software and so someone gets a result
where you get significant results and
you know here the answer is 2:23 but
then someone tried to run my software
and they got 228 you're like oh no you
have to downgrade
we there was a bug that we got around in
this way but if you use the bug fix then
you're gonna get something else didn't
on Mac rather than Linux and they get a
different answer but you'd rather have
is everyone running with the thing in
the same box so the tool you have for
that is for our users in docker is this
great thing called the rocker project
the rocker project was started by Carl
betta turns or kettle mattel crawl is
one of the founders of our open sigh
Dirk you may know of as the creator of
our cpp for putting C++ programs into
our they've created this great project
where they have a huge number of our
base docker images that let me without
having to design the whole setup
themselves what they do is provide whole
library of docker images that have
different sets of packages installed
different associated operating systems
and system libraries and they have it
for every version of our going back five
years you know going back to each patch
version so all of these stacks like you
may want just base are you may want our
with our studio installed in it you may
want our with all the tidy verse
packages on it and you may want that for
our three point three point two and you
can just grab any of those off of docker
hub under the rocker or organization in
order to run in that particular image
and then you can modify those for your
particular that's going back and doing
all the startup components so let's take
a look at how one actually oh I have an
analysis that's very important done a
lot of important research to show that
there is a relationship between GDP and
life expectancy in the world and I want
to make sure that anybody else can run
that and that I would be able to run
that in six months from now or can it
bring infrastructure that I'm currently
doing now so I didn't find that most of
us you know that we have we have a
script maybe a git repository a set of
data all these components that we need
to reproduce the analysis we also have
to define the environment so a docker
file the docker file is just a series of
imperative commands to define it there's
a very simple docker file because it
only has to do a couple of things
because we're going to start the docker
file by saying we're gonna use as our
basis for it using the from command the
rocker taiji verse three point three
point two so I'm gonna have an image
that installs R and the tidy verse and
it will use a version 3.3.4 the package
is associated with three point three
point two I am one command that just
means tagging it with my names which
people can know where this image came
from and then I have one command to
install a dependency so I use the run
command to run a line which is a shell
script which is install a package
because Gapminder is the package that is
not in the tidy verse but is part of my
analysis
dependency and then the final line is
just to add the file analysis dot R into
this docker image and we're gonna put it
in a folder called home our studio so we
think I need to run this that can be
shipped around is defined in this docker
file and I'll have to do is build my
environment with a few dr commands so
the dr. build command here lets me build
tag the image as my analysis and just
specify the folder that I'm doing which
is example one a rocker I think get this
right no problem can I run that in a
terminal and what it does is each of
these steps so grab the rocker tidy
verse image three point three point two
I have previously downloaded this and I
have in my computer if I hadn't it would
have pulled it from docker hub um I
wasn't sure about the Wi-Fi connectivity
here so I put all these on my cuter
ahead of time just pull that thing down
and then it goes to each of the steps it
runs ads the maintainer tag it runs this
script once again I'm speeding things up
by the fact that docker automatically
having built this before is saving these
build commands in a case and so if I
didn't have that it would actually see
that you know the installing package
component and then I add the file it
builds the image and then it tags it and
I called it my analysis if I don't give
a sub tag it always calls it latest so I
have an image and you turn an image into
a running container with docker run so I
can run this docker image with docker
run I'm gonna attach it to a port this
says make the day seven eight seven my
party at seven eight seven and they're
on this thing called my analysis and
they're running in the background so I
run that it gives me a very long tag
which is the name of the image but if we
use the command docker PS it will list
docker containers running and in
addition to a long confusing hash for
the name who also gives a name in this
case priceless Colton docker always
gives an adjective in the name of a
scientist to give your containers unique
name and so that's just step fires up
eleven seconds ago off the my analysis
image and it has port 8 7 8 7 8 7 8 7
and we are placed into an art studio
environment so you can see that we are
running our three points three point two
here which is different my computer is
on a three point five it has the tidy
verse packages and the Gapminder package
it has and so I can run everything in
here exactly as I ran it elsewhere and
if I ship this image to somebody else I
push it to docker hub anyone else can
run this the same way now built things
get more complex so that's the nice
thing about the rocker project it has
all of these pre-built images that have
most of what you want but they're a
bunch of other interesting tools for
getting your docker file environment
together particularly for our so one of
these is the container it package
container impact can your directory of
files or a low tier session info figure
out the current or the current version
of our that you're running if there are
system dependencies are those packages
and the right the docker for you so you
just read your session echo it writes
that docker file it can then you can
just build that image and usually it
gets all the default or up the defaults
right for you it grabs the right rocker
images the base and it has little
components for you so that's super
helpful you don't have to write every
docker file there's another version of
this specifically for our markdown
documents if you don't want to have lots
of files lying around you just trying to
compress everything into one file
there's a package called lifter lifter
just lets you put all your docker
associated metadata
in that yellow header of your dockerfile
so in addition to your title and author
and date and what one looks like you
just have a lifter field and you can say
you know what your basis of the v-rocker
file is whether you need panda to build
things whether you need tech to build
things and what your system dependencies
are or packages installed from different
repositories so that too will create a
docker file and lifter has command
render docker which will fire up the
docker file run the render command to
get your output you know just shut it
all down and then rather than just
knitting or rendering your our markdown
in your current environment it's
happening in the environment it's
defined in the header of the file so it
tries to get all of that sort of docker
workflow into just you know that button
that says knit at the top of those
things both help you at the end of
setting up your doctor environment but
you also may want to distribute it and
there's this fantastic tool called
binder binder was originally designed
for distributing Jupiter notebook but
there's our studio all sorts of other
environments now as well I don't
remember exactly how they fun this but
if you have a github repository with a
docker file in it defining a Jupiter or
our studio environment binder will
simply launch a server running that
image for you for free it's not the like
most you know resource extensive one but
it's great for letting anyone else toy
around with analysis that you have and
so if your analysis is open source for
instance
and they published a paper on ecological
noise phenomena and he just has a link
in here for launch binder all that does
is send binder the URL of the repository
and so there's just a bad you add to
your repository you do that it takes you
to binder it will fire up the repository
it's pulling the image it launches a
server and in a minute here you will end
up with that same our studio environment
that Carl used to do the analysis that
he ran his did the analysis that he used
to publish that paper and so this year
is his research repository the version
of our that he was using all the
packages that he was using in student
custom ones and you've got the paper
itself as an hour markdown file that you
can under or you could grab the code and
eat yourself there's sort of layers to
this and that you could grab that code
and try to run it on your own computer
but if it's not working for you the
dependency problem this lets you get
there instantly and you don't need any
infrastructure and it's a good example
of you're really deploying this
reproducible container as a service for
people to use
give you another example of how you
might try to sort of package up work
environment maybe you want to create a
container that is common for the tools
and the problems that your team is using
so EcoHealth
we have a container called reservoir
reservoir is based off the geospatial
rocker project but it has a bunch of
other machine learning and a bunch of
other sort of commission communication
tools within it it runs on our high
performance server it also runs on our
new high performance server so I didn't
have to configure that server I just
moved move the image over so the same
thing works there if we need to spin up
in an environment with different
resources on Amazon if our local stuff
goes down and you move to the cloud the
container is available to use so it has
sort of the things we commonly use on a
day to day basis and if I need to update
it I say that in the docker file and
then like bringing the server down to do
it I like to make sure the docker file
bills run in a different place and then
when it's working well I just shut down
the old image and start up the new one
and so that makes sure that we have a
common environment that we could work in
in different places and it's also a good
way to manage a common working
environment for people this
reproducibility box isn't actually why
doctor was really originally designed
though docker was designed as a way of
firing up and delivering services in
sort of rapid ways so one of ours great
advantage is his ability to work with
things that are not hard when like S was
created the idea was to provide access
to compiled statistical libraries in
Fortran and C and as time has gone on R
has had a lot more connectors different
types of things in Java and in Python
and to web services and you can think of
docker as a way to package up anything
that would iran in a linux box as a
service that are can call and so you
might do this sort of a custom at it as
for a custom service yourself you have
an api that you want to run locally that
are can connect to and then there are
also packages that are specifically
built around the ID
that there is a service or a server in
docker that you want to run so some of
those include browser rendering services
for web scraping so splasher and Selita
and selenium are both frameworks for web
scraping that have a server that's
running a headless browser and a series
of commands to control that browser and
a bunch of software software to render
and transfer information from that
browser for either testing apps or web
scraping so those live in a docker
container that in our package calls
there's another neat one called the
open-source robbing machine which is
basically a sort of a Google Max Maps
our app finder using Open Street Map
data so it's a series of libraries that
live in a docker container that you can
communicate with they have the version
on the web you can call it you know the
web site but that's slower and they have
only so much capacity but you can just
run the whole thing locally on your
machine to pull those to pull those
routes and then you know machine
learning services like h2o if anyone's
familiar - Oh h2o is a job application
Java applications can be difficult to
get configured properly and deal with
installation but you can run it h2o in a
docker image and do all the same things
and you don't have to you know work with
different versions of Java installation
so if we're to use docker to run
something like a web scraping service
we're not building an image what we're
doing is we're pulling an image using
and communicating with that image and
that image has nothing to do with our
itself doesn't have our installed as
whatever splash has which says some
combination of Python and something else
I don't actually remember and it doesn't
really matter so if I want to use
something like this I can load up my
stevedore library to control docker
containers and then the splash our
package which is what
indicated the dr. client and then I just
create a container has been full or will
be pulled from docker hub if I need it
I think it's ports to open I see that
container running on my machine with
sort of steam you can query the
container that that is you can get you
know so that's running you know the name
never thought that you can issue
commands on the container that way and
now the commands in the splash package
they are just sending HTTP requests to
that container to tell it what to do and
get information back so this is an
example where we're visiting the CDC
website that shows flu cases get to the
website and maybe you want to get this
graph but you have to get past this
disclaimer and want to display
with splat that we're running on our
local computer at port 8050 because
that's what we opened up in the back
sort of hole pipe opening you know
fire it up to visit the press enter and
so when I run that our is just sending
commands back and forth rather than to a
server on the web to a server running on
your own machine the sort of micro
service and it's waiting a bit so that
at the CDC you can load but it just is
in the end well you know return the
image of the website that I'm looking
for they might be doing all sorts of
other things grabbing a table scraping
the data processing it but rather than
installing splash and it's Python
dependencies all those things we run
splash in the container when you're done
you can stop a container you can check
that that's container has exited and
actually made this thing a little more
complex more complex than I need to for
demonstration purposes because the
splash package itself just has a command
start splash that does this and if you
look inside it they're actually using
the docker around the stevedore package
but the syntax is almost exactly the
same it's firing up the client starting
the image and returning that so you
can't run all of that in then there's a
stop splash container that does the same
thing
so that's what you do when you have are
on the outside and another service on
the inside like this we want to call all
of these other programs that you want to
package up and not deal with
installation but then you can go the
other way around you can have are inside
a box and then you want to deliver
services or data or other things to a
different program to a website to a
different framework where people are
pulling data from or just sort of
deliver your data sources or your models
especially to some larger some larger
software frameworks some larger app or
web service that needs to call your our
programs but our is not part of you know
what your Web Services team works with
but docker package is what a Web
Services team could totally work with
they're like oh yeah we can run that
it's on this port when our Python or
JavaScript or other components needs to
call this they'll just ask the question
on the port will get the number back the
predictor the chart that you generated
any of those things and so they're a
bunch of different types of our services
you might create probably the one you're
most familiar for most people are most
familiar with this is shine you generate
a web app so you can have a web app in a
docker container that can run anywhere
there's another similar framework called
firey which is like a much more
low-level uh opinionated way to generate
generate websites tomorrow or you might
not be delivering and interact and
interactive user facing thing you might
be delivering services and the REST API
is for a different group to work with
you can do that with program call a
package called plumber or another one
called open CPU both for developing REST
API s and then what we did before
showing the our studio environment or a
similar Jupiter environment those are
sort of environments delivered as
services as well so you
in addition to just you know having that
package product you are delivering a
service of letting people work on it for
you as well so all of these things are
different ways you might want something
that is are running in a box that can
move around that other people can access
you want it I stole this one from Plaza
sort of a typical shiny program we have
a bunch of library calls the top two
define what we need we do some
pre-processing of data there's a user
interface component and a service
component in this case the shiny program
just demonstrates some of the
interactivity and crosstalk that you can
have between data tables and plotly and
so you put that all together it exports
of shiny app shiny apples on finding our
machine how do we get that shiny app to
other places well once again we define a
docker file so in this case again I'm
going to start the doctor foul and tidy
verse so I have all those packages
available tag it with my name and then
install the packages using the shiny
shiny app so I have DT and pop lead and
crosstalk you know shining itself here
because I have this other line which has
a sort of confusing component and this
comes from the rocker project itself has
set up a command that installs shiny and
all the shiny server dependencies so you
can add shiny to any of the rocker
images so you might want the tidy verse
image with shiny you might want the
debian edged version with shiny or you
may may want an older version with shiny
so you just run this add this command
which is on the
the rocker documentation you get shiny
attitude package and then you import
your app itself and put it in the shiny
servers serving directory so we can fire
this up this time I'll do it tomorrow as
Michelle I'll load stevedore and the
darker client you're gonna build off of
the shiny directory and call it shap it
runs all of those commands so now we
have a built-in inch which we call shap
and then we can run shap as a container
and go to it now so the shiny container
on port three eight three eight is
running this plotly app which happens
elect to do interactive selection and so
if you're building something that's to
live going to you know a user fifteen
this can be site may be just ends up you
know you know like in a frame within a
larger component of your organization's
site or maybe you're like well I've
written this but I have no idea how to
deploy it what if it has to be full a
lot of people you know sort of a
development operations group can just
take this and like oh yeah we can set
this up so it can scale and there'll be
a thousand instances of it so every time
it gets tapped you many people will fire
up a new one all they have to do is run
the docker container and have that
trigger that stop that
I have another demo here of plumber if
you're building an API where you want to
serve predictions or data plumbers are
relatively it's been around awhile
they've really only invested well
recently it comes from Jeff Palin who's
in our studio
it lets you define functions that will
act as a REST API endpoints so you can
send echo to this service and it will
return an echo over the message saying
this message is which is not super
exciting you can send plot and you'll
get a random plot you can send some and
parameters and add some numbers to it
but if you can write a function you can
write a function that generates
predictions from your X G boost model
and so someone who's crying the service
to generate a month saying what's the
prediction of the you know best pizza
restaurant
that you're looking for you can just
have a function R that does that deliver
it as a service and then of course we
want that service to integrate with
someone's site through being a doctoring
an engine and so we'll just pull the
plumber docker image that has all the
plumber dependencies in it tag it at our
app this is a particular modification of
what the startup command is in this
docker and then do which says fire up
plumber and I just added this because it
lets me add this swagger command here
which shows which automatically
generates swagger documentation for my
API and then we run the app itself so
in this case we'll put it on C build it
here put it on a port I guess I ran it
twice so it says ports already allocated
because we already have one so this one
at 4,000 is festive chebyshev and if we
visit that I have a web service that
delivers an image every time someone
calls this API endpoint refresh we have
that our process running is returning an
object to you you know you know you can
also say add with parameters a equals
three and B equals five and you get this
very led you here not have some it's a
very exciting response but it's the same
service and no one cares what's running
underneath that service is the main
point and no one cares exactly how to
install the things you have both the
output and the startup are just
pluggable and sort of anyone's web
infrastructure
finally let's see
if you're just like with lifter or
container it if you're building a shiny
app and it has a bunch of dependencies
and you want to create a complex docker
file to make sure all those pieces are
there
the Ryze package does that for shiny
apps it finds all the pieces necessary
for the shiny after on it assembled your
docker file you know might have to you
know all of these you might have to
tweak or maybe you have an efficiency
improvement but they give you a really
great start the final thing you might
want to use docker for is deploying big
compute jobs so docker container is
something that can move between
infrastructures and so if you have a big
job that needs to use a bunch of
different cloud services or a bunch of
different computers you can send that
job in the form of a docker file and get
the results back and so if you something
that really needs to scale up in terms
of compute docker is a way to do it
often you don't have to build the images
and send them because that
infrastructure has at least docker
installed on it so you can build and run
the containers there rather than build
them and send them along I'm not going
to go through a detailed example here
but this is when I was actually just
working on the other day for some of my
own fluff this stuff if you're familiar
with the future package or parallel
computing it's a really sort of great
framework for sending jobs to any
background process and getting it back
and so I had set up a thing where I made
a cluster of multiple computers on my
network and then it has this one
parameter called our script and normally
that just says what's the command to run
our on that machine so when we send they
when we send the commands we can run
that command on that machine rather than
having a path to our itself I said run a
docker image and around our and so when
I send a job to that it will fire up the
docker image
there and send the results back so it's
something you would send a big job to
you don't want to send something fire
but docker image you know add ten
numbers together and get them back but
if you have something that's
long-running you know this is a good way
you can just integrate this into
something that you might already have
sort of a standard say no send it to
that computer and use docker to run our
rather than on my computer to do
something else this works with a lot of
services the future package itself has
like templates for doing this
specifically already with Amazon Web
site and Google compute and it probably
works with a juror and I should probably
figure that out at some point there's a
package Google compute R that has like
pre-built docker templates for Google
compute ours docker service you're just
like send this docker template with this
one additional components the job and
it'll build the image fire the job up
there and get things back which is
really great as well
if you are deploying big jobs there's
actually a very similar 'native which
you might want to consider there's a
program called singularity that is a
very similar portable container set up
to docker and as it's sort of
specifically designed for this big
compute delivery service kind of thing
some of the important differences are
that you don't need admin rights on any
machine to run it so you know it might
not just be that you on some machine you
can't install are you also can't install
docker and it's not pre-installed you're
using someone's cluster or supercomputer
can pull down singularity in around
with no they're not basically for
running a service they've done for
designed for running a workflow or a
batch job or some utility one time and
so they tend to have access to the file
system someone said like docker is like
an alternate universe but singularity
are parallel universes that have you
know occasional ships in the timeline so
it's more like it'll take your current
machine and like pull out the operating
system and put a different one
underneath it I haven't actually used it
but um the important thing is it can run
the docker images - so you can grab a
docker image and run it within the
singularity you don't have to build up
everything in scratch you can still use
the rocker project or something else and
but I put it in because when I posted
this today
Honore thanks Jenny dated the future
package and there's a lot of state
compute you know next job San Francisco
State doing biomedical work said you
know doing the big compute stuff is a
lot easier on singularities so it's not
my endorsement but it's definitely a
possibility because what people like it
as well I'm gonna post the slides and
actually a whole bunch of links to
different things that I talked about
online as well so there's gonna be a lot
more than this but docker has really
great and comprehensive documentation
you have to remember that it's like
written primarily for people who are
building web services and doing large
conformed container orchestration
they're not necessarily thinking about
the data scientists are all when you're
doing it up inside put together a lot
more oh you're not everything you do
there is no sorry the same you do it now
but it's a good introduction to the
process and it has the students to the
walkthrough and said everything is will
be up tomorrow at my github with docker
talk so thank you very much
and imagine
[Applause]
well
[Music]
I mean suddenly in terms of other I mean
this is a huge number of projects that
are using
[Music]
um I think only singularity doug's if I
have it right
vagrant works with docker is an
orchestration package so it will run
virtual machines and will also run
docker images so it's a more general
thing then there's also like there's all
these add-ons to the machine that are to
the various and then there's the whole
doctors operating system setup
configuring the sort of multiple but I
think only singularity will run docker
images or creation so that containers
would be interoperable that I followed
enough honestly to tell you if there's
any more than that
I don't know what any of those things
are yeah
[Music]
necessarily load what is like the docker
environment into another environment per
se there are things you can share
between your computer and the docker
environment so you can share directories
between docker and your computer you can
mount the directory in sick this data
directory this project directory when I
run say our studio or Jupiter and
doctoral there'll be a folder there and
that's the folder that's also on my
machine
so like typically what I end up doing if
I have something as a that sort of has a
docker environment cuz I'm a running our
studio through that and I run that
through the browser but I'm running on
files in my machine just as I'm running
those off that moving sort of the
environment component out I don't think
you can do because that's what sort of
indices to use that environment on other
projects that live on your machine
I mean honestly what I typically do is
I'm running locally and then I run it
also in the docker container to make
sure that everything is appropriate
right so like I can be a little fast and
loose on you know the ongoing basis but
you know before I want to commit it up
before I want to transfer it I'm making
sure things are running in the docker
environment cause that's the
standardization that's you might do that
interactively or sort of a common
pattern is just to use a docker a docker
just driven commands to run your tests
so all the tests occur in the docker and
then you get them back and that's fine
and you don't necessarily have to be
running image all the time in your
ongoing so the development
[Music]
so there's a lot less than you know sort
of a virtual machine one of the biggest
things it used to be and it's gotten
much better that like that thought that
movement between file systems and so
mounting the docker file system on the
Mac file system meant that reading and
writing lots of files got particularly
slow that's less the case though it's
still a little bit one of the
bottlenecks but the thing is you don't
have separate memory like the thing
about the difference between docker and
having like a total isolated virtual
machine and this which is actually just
isolating processes is that really
lowers the overhead on things related to
like RAM and CPU access and you really
don't get much of a penalty at all
I've been trying out some cases recently
with looking at GPU and making sure that
docker on GP on GPU machines are unwell
and that's like all like at least you
know well over 95% of with the
performances on the raw machines so
that's you know that's the reason this
has become popular it's like that
overhead problem is what people wanted
to solve in order to be able to scale
things up
I guess it really depends you know like
how much you care about performance and
you know sort of what you're like if all
problem performance is all you care
about right like you know you know your
optimization space like it's all over
towards performance is a little bit but
it's a pretty minor for the most part
and you know really the case is
specialized hardware the case where
you're more likely to run into that so
you know it's a matter of priorities
so if I remember right and I'm not sure
about this Gabor Azhar who's a member of
our studio team and the creator of a
huge number of packages one of the
things he did is when he was building a
project called our hub
he built a database of all the system
dependencies for packages on kram and so
you know you go to a cran web page and
it's like you need licks live XML to
deaf devs in order to install this
package and so it was a matter of like
scraping all those files and building
that database and maintaining it and so
that service lose at this point so when
you get a package you can query the our
hub database if I remember this
correctly and that's how you get system
in the dependencies that you can install
in a way through app to get on you know
on Linux Debian Debian a UNIX
Oh
right so does it I mean this is there's
lots of ways so right so I mean one
option is that you just pull like the
docker you don't need the wherever you
have those things right like at some
places the place you have the code base
right so the private repository where
you have the code you're also pulling in
data from other places in that private
repository with the code you have the
docker file and so the first thing you
do for big ass simulation on is build
off the dick docker file and run it and
you just have to say docker on that
directory and it will first you know
build the docker file and then around
the command essentially so that's option
one if like building the thing takes a
long time because you have a big ass
compile before you're a big ass
simulation then right and you just want
that compile to like happen in the build
stage then you probably an s3 can store
as a blob the image itself right and
then you can say pull the image from
blob or my paid docker hub account or
anything along those lines and they are
gonna pull down that image which might
be you know like three gigabytes of
system dependencies and you know
operating system and then I run it yeah
and you could also put the data in that
image too if you want to say building
the image includes importing the data
and one of the commands when you can
move that around if that's not sort of
as active a portion of the simulation
[Music]
there may be destroyed potato howdy-doo
generated artifacts from the user
why
[Music]
I'm like other so you have a work flow
and once and we're talking about an
interactive workflow and not just like
we're running a pipeline it's coming out
right I mean now it's like you have your
spun off docker environment people use
that son of doctor environment and then
like you know if you were working in an
interactive context without docker you
know what this is there we just have
slightly different versions of our then
you have to have a place that you're you
know you can push those to a cup it can
be github or maybe you are producing
things that are you know big blog and
say we have an s3 storage container that
we share and so here donor on your
analysis you push up there if you're not
mounting the local volume you have to do
that because otherwise when you shut
down your docker image it's going away
or you run off your you know you run off
you when you fire up your running mount
through the local directory and even
when you shut down those files are still
there but if you have an interactive
workflow that you have an interactive
step of sending those outputs someplace
as well and so you sort of have to do
that same thing be it in a docker
environment or not
so your so you have different you can
have different versions in a given a
repo so I'll give you actually that's
way to do this is if I go to pub let's
go to rocker and say versioned right so
rocker our version is the the repo
within that repo there are all of these
different versions of it you know for
all the different are versions
um it's not forking per se there are two
ways to there are two ways to get an
image different ways to get individual
dog or maybe three you can have an
automated build which points to a github
repo or something similar and that's
just pointing to where our docker file
is and docker hub will automatically run
that docker file build the image every
time it changes over there so I keep the
git repo I can have different subfolders
or branches and I can say for each of
those branches or repos build something
and give it a different tag also you can
just build something and push it and you
can give it a different tag within the
same repo so what a rocker does and what
I do is actually like I use a different
CI service I use Circle CI I push up
there I run the image I test it and when
it's done it pushes it to docker hub to
make sure it's there and there's two
versions of those cuz I have one of
those that's like GPU enabled and once
not you GPU enabled so it builds both of
those pushes one with the GPU tag one
without the GPU tag
Hey
I will
Piper's thank you Thank You Jerry